[Music]
after going through the stuff i'd
written to recap a decade of anime i
thought that you were really into the
action anime one then it dawned on me
why don't i take one request to recap
some of the great action anime from a
decade further so here we are we'll take
another deep dive down memory lane and
i'll try and give you a review of what
the anime world was back like in the
2000s now don't quote me on this but i
think that this is where a lot of the
current anime fans got their start oh in
the glorious 2000s for some of us
including me these shows are the ones
that paved the way for us to become the
anime fans that we are today i'll be
running with series clause this time so
that means that i won't be counting
sequels for picking my show of the year
although i've learnt my lesson from the
previous video what that means is that
really excellent sequels that went far
beyond their prequels will get an
honorable mention at least but you know
before we talk about the shows that have
made their marks on history how about we
look at a game that began to make its
mark in the mobile gaming community just
a couple of years ago yes i'm talking
about the sponsors of this video raid
shadow legends raid shadow legends is a
fantasy themed rpg that takes you to the
world of talaria where you've got to
gather armies muster your forces and
liberate the kingdom from the dark lord
siroth but what good is a game without a
constant slew of challenges headed your
way introducing the doom tower a prison
made to lock up the nastiest villains
the world's ever seen before well after
thousands of years the seal's slowly
being undone and it's only a matter of
time before these villains come out and
raise havoc so it's up to us heroes to
go in there and finish the job for good
these tough bosses are no slouch and
they'll demolish all those who dare
enter unprepared team composition
strategy properly trained specialists
you need to use everything you've
learned to even stand a chance against
these behemoths besides that raid has
other new stuff coming up this month
headlining those is the new feature that
allows you new ways to use your
champions the guardian ring use this new
system to break through the limits and
become even more powerful not to mention
that the game will be implementing an
exciting and extremely anticipated
feature in december if you want to get a
huge head start in raid all you have to
do is hit the link in the description or
scan my qr code and you'll get the epic
hero chinoroo who's amazing in the doom
tower 200k silver one xp boost one
energy refill and one ancient shard so
you can summon an awesome champion as
soon as you get in game all this
treasure is waiting for you here and so
am i keep in mind these rewards will be
only available for new players and only
for the next 30 days so what are you
waiting for jump on the raid hype train
now
2 000
when everyone looked at the year 2000 as
the end of the world or a massive
reckoning which would break computers
everywhere it was the anime world that
opened with a bang you see back then the
world didn't have 50 shows to watch
every season and anime series typically
ran for way longer these long runners
were the norm as far as popular anime
that saw light outside of japan were
concerned and so are the shows that had
anywhere from 20 to 30-ish episodes
among those i feel my pick for the year
2000 anime would have to be hajime no
ippo yep the fan favorite anime did get
its start in october of that year and it
kick-started a franchise that would
eventually give us nearly a hundred
episodes of hyped fights intense drama
and a journey that let us experience the
blood swear and tears these fighters go
through in their road to absolute glory
for this year though it was a very very
close call in terms of being a straight
up action series full of hype fights
ippo takes this one easily but in terms
of fantasy adventures with a more
balanced narrative inuyasha is pretty
damn good it's isakai before it was cool
and it captured the hearts of the youth
worldwide it's a phenomenon that dragged
boys and girls into anime thanks to the
romance the adventure and the corn and
cute characters now i personally felt
that the only thing hampering inuyasha
is how the plot seems to show little
progress at some point and the amount of
fillers something that it shares with a
lot of long running shonen around this
time this year also introduced us to
cult classic flcl oh and sayuki got its
start here too journey to the west for a
fujo bait and legitimately awesome
action count me in
2001.
2021's the year where one of my favorite
childhood shonen got its start this year
its name shaman king ever since i was
young the world of spirits had always
captivated me and this is the series
that showed me how cool it is through
the lens of anime by all regards i think
the shaman king could have taken the
crown for 2001's action anime of the
year except it couldn't quite hold on to
the momentum later on i mean don't get
me wrong the second half of the anime
had some really cool moments and i stand
by my opinion that some of the
anime-only compromises turned out better
than their manga counterparts for me i
think that the crown this year belongs
to barky bucky at that time was an
innovator it pushed the boundaries of
what people considered can be normal for
a modern day fighting show and dazzled
everyone with its absurdities in
over-the-top fighting a stark contrast
from ippo definitely while baki didn't
become quite as popular as a lot of its
peers around this era there's no denying
its legacy not every show could get
continuations decades ago but our boy
barki did it with a bang actually now
that i think about it i've been leaning
towards fighting shows for two years
already don't worry it's all going to
change next year because a storm is
about to shake the anime world
2002
if we're talking about influence and
legacy there's absolutely no doubt that
2002's anime of the year is naruto the
show that shaped the 2000s anime world
outside japan got its start this year
and it was a runaway success now you can
say what you want about naruto there's
really no denying the lasting influence
it left on the anime world though how
many people started getting into the
medium back then i'm sure there were
hordes of them and you've got this
jumpsuit wearing ninja and his edgy
lightning power to thank for that you
know i don't want naruto to overshadow
the blessings the anime world gifted us
this year though full metal panic for
one and it's one of the mecca shows that
are dear to my heart if you want more
sci-fi goodness let me remind you that
2002 is also when ghost in the shell
stand-alone complex released also i
don't know how many people watched this
one but i loved get backers it's another
shonen that debuted in 2002 and i really
enjoyed following the duo's adventures
as a young kid i'm pretty sure that it's
the show that opened the eyes of many
anime fans to the concept of traps too
if that's anything
2003
with naruto fever being in full throttle
here it's not easy to see why a lot of
shows got overshadowed still some brave
contenders rise up to the challenge with
mixed results in the forefront of those
is fma the original one people vastly
hyped brotherhood over the original fma
to the point that i think that the
latter's become underrated make sure you
chime in on that one in the comments
section if you think so the anime world
around this time also seems to be toying
with the idea of hard sci-fi a lot while
cyberpunk or hard sci-fi settings
weren't as big of a trend as isakai in
the past few years the selection of key
action anime is pretty telling he had
ghosts in the shell and fmp the previous
year and 2003 gave us technology last
exile gun grave and my favorite pick for
anime of the year kino's journey kino's
journey is an adventure anime that has
quite the different approach you'd
expect shows like this to have a
gunslinging protagonist who goes from
town to town shooting down the bad guys
and just generally being cool however
kino's journey is quite contemplative
instead of a long narrative the series
is episodic and focuses more on the wide
range of characters and cultures in its
very vast world it's quite the
intelligent show that deals with a
varied spectrum of themes now it's a
unique approach that caught me off guard
when i first watched it i think that it
was around that time that i really saw
the power of the medium despite me still
loving the action shows more kino's
journey was an eye-opener it's a show
that i'd gladly recommend to anyone to
this day
2004.
2004 was quite the eventful year don't
you agree quick google searches would
reveal that this is the year that
popular shows like elephant lead and
gantt made their debut continuing with
the sci-fi train as you can see there
now with the dash of psychological
throning it's really an aesthetic that
you can associate with this era of anime
right the more western oriented
aesthetic and ambiance that a number of
people are wishing the anime would go
back to oh and samurai shamplo a show
that i've repeatedly talked good things
about also got it started this year it's
got a very unique atmosphere to it that
makes it stand out so much until now
when you say that hip hop samurai anime
there can only be one of course and it's
a show that i'm imploring you to watch
this year's pick however well what i
think is visually the coolest among the
big three shonen is bleach i don't talk
about bleach as much as one piece or
naruto in my videos but make no mistake
it's the most stylish amongst the three
of them it's got that oomph that makes
it so awesome to like maybe it's the
character designs which exude rebel teen
energy something that i vastly prefer
over the more whimsical and cartoony
designs of most shonen before this era
there's also the sheikai and bankai that
came in all shades of cool thanks to the
brilliance of daite gubo ghostbusters
turned into dragon ball z with magical
sword samurais and battles against gods
how epic can you be easily anime of the
year 2005.
for me 2005's were the transition to the
next era of anime started while the
anime sphere was quite heavy on sci-fi
the midpoint of the decades where things
started transitioning to softer sci-fi
instead of robots and steampunk settings
we now begin to see more anime taking
place in the modern neighborhood filled
with supernatural elements lore of yueki
comes to mind and i hope that more
people will share their fond memories of
this one then a perennial favorite of
mine with the urban fantasy setting is
shakugan no shana i do have a strong
bias for it but i came really close to
crowning it this year ultimately it
stands as a runner-up side by side with
my personal pick for this year blood
plus way before the vampire craze blood
plus gave us a glimpse of it as it
combines horror and action that while
may not seem too original in terms of
premise ended up being an awesome ride
it's an action show that carefully
trends the line between pg-13 and r18
and as teenagers nothing can be cooler
for us back in the day than that right
overall blood plus is probably one of
the more generally good shows that i can
recommend to people thanks to its high
octane action and sleek art and
animation plus not a lot of fan service
or cliches often associated with anime
these days and that's speaking in a
relative manner still the high fantasy
and medievalist settings aren't dead
with that basilisk subasa chronicle and
trinity blood for those who wanted some
hot blooded sports action 2005 also gave
us eye shield 21
2006.
2006
is
a
banger there's no other way to put it so
let's get on with this amazing year as
said in the series clause standout
sequels will be given shout outs so
here's to helsing ultimate thanks for
your help in making 2006 awesome good
friend dean stay night it also made its
debut in 2006 and we at the time had no
idea what the fate series would end up
turning into the following decade it
shows that some of the most hyped anime
movie trilogies and video game cash cows
all had to start from humble beginnings
ray kugimiya continues to roll in
cementing her status as the 2000 sunday
queen with a familiar of zero it's
around this time that the sharna clones
have started coming around and gogimiya
herself would continue getting
star-making roles the next few years in
non-action anime mind you shonen shows
continue trying to make their mark with
varied levels of success while d greyman
is now more known for the manga going on
hiatus it was a big deal back then the
latte can be said of hitman reborn
although that manga had the benefit of
ending conclusively to a mixed reception
2006 though came down to two mega hits
that shaped the anime landscape on one
hand you have code geass hailed by many
as one of the greatest anime ever made
it's not hard to argue with the facts
it's such a cultural landmark that
continues to get new movies and series
made and it really made such a big
impact with its masterful mixing of
genres you get the mecca the
psychological the political peppered by
the handsome guys and waifus it would
have been a no-brainer to give code
ghias the crown but it unfortunately ran
into another powerhouse series of 2006
gintama gintama also does the genre
mixing well comedy action drama i mean
need i say more it goes all out in
parodies and gives you fits of laughter
before slamming you with some of the
most epic sword fights and brawls that
you've ever seen in anime then it hits
you hard with touching backstories that
will stick with you for years to come
gintama is truly an amazing anime that
recently got a sendoff whose quality is
just as it deserved both shows are very
good contenders for anime of the year
and i've got to give guinta the edge
just ever so slightly let me leave 2006
with this question will you get with
gintama over code geass or you have it
the other way round
2007
after the blockbuster year that 2006 was
it would understandably be hard to get
quite on that level and honestly kind of
felt that way too while 2007 didn't have
any hits that could be on par with code
gias it did have some heavyweights of
its own look at it this way 2007 is the
year that unleashed gurren lagann to the
world and we all know how that went a
hot-blooded visual spectacle that people
remember and loved to this very day i'd
also consider 2007 the year of action
movies if anything just as a footnote
this is the year we got the first garden
of sinners the first of the eva rebuild
movies as well as sword of the stranger
more underrated hits continued in this
year with moribito and darker than black
the latter decisively more popular and
the western aesthetics in anime are also
alive with claymore afro samurai and my
pick for this year boccano
what makes picano so good well i could
start with a nice mixture of genres
along with a slight supernatural
backdrop if you've noticed actually a
lot of my picks so far have this thing
where contrasting genres like comedy
drama and action get mixed in a way that
one element doesn't hamper everything
else and instead it all just complements
each other it makes the show easily
introduced to newbies and it really
helps if the show is devoid of the usual
fan service or extreme violence that a
lot of people who didn't know better
would actually associate with the medium
amongst those shows i think that it's
pacano that does this balancing act the
best while pairing it with those good
old oldies feel in terms of atmosphere
and tone i wouldn't call it emblematic
of what you'd expect of these hidden gem
anime of this era but it's one of those
shows that you can take one look at and
immediately get a flashback of a bygone
era in anime's history it's also got a
dub with a stellar reputation so you
might want to check that out too
2008
as we approach the end of the decade we
start seeing those big hitters not to
say that these shows are any less good
but it's just that the action series
around this time never reached the
influence the previous big hit has had
off the top of my head the most popular
amongst the 2008 badge is possibly a
certain magical index yet another urban
fantasy that i love look i just love
these urban fantasies with supernatural
elements and pseudo-harems if it's not
obvious by now in its time index was
wildly popular and spawn numerous
spin-offs while it's a shell of itself
now in terms of popularity the a certain
series of anime still ends up making a
bit of noise when new titles get
announced i think more people like
railgun a lot better though 2008 also
had black butler probably on par with
index in terms of popularity the first
season i mean i really loved it the
second season
not so much but it's still a landmark
show that got a lot of female fans into
the whole anime thing it's not just for
the girls though remember and i'll vouch
for the interesting developments and
plot that the first season gave us start
for the premise and the banger opening
by sid stay for the suspenseful plot and
the action ultimately the win goes to
soul eater while the previous two titles
of their niches an index in particular
has a universe that's a can of worms
which isn't quite different from the
fate series solita's a more accessible
show to get into it's an entertaining
supernatural action show that has a
little of everything and could help a
prospective viewer ease into an anime
watching habit while lacking the
gratuitous levels of fan service that
the creators otherworld fire force had
gotten flak for other niche hits in this
era include birdie the mighty and real
drive if the synopsis interest you you
should definitely check those ones out
2009
now i find myself in a bit of a bind
remember the series clause it prevents
me from outright crowning what many
consider to be one of the best anime of
all time yes the king of my anime list
everyone's favorite fma brotherhood the
title is well deserved too personally i
think perfection is something that is
statistically impossible but fma
brotherhood just has so many things
going for it whether you like it for the
plot the character stories the drama the
art the themes and meaning or just all
of it fmab has something that would
strike deep and embed itself into your
heart for years to come heck i throw the
show into contention for anime of the
decade and i'm confident that it would
definitely get the win that's just how
good it is with the consensus action
anime of the year out of the running
what are we left with then well phantom
eden of the east sengoku basala canaan
oh fairy tale also got its start this
year so let's go with that one it's not
a debate that among those i mentioned
fairy tale is by far the show that gets
the mainstream appeal a light-hearted
adventure show that takes us through the
sights and sound of hiro mashima's
colorful world managed to garner quite a
lot of love from anime fans you can say
what you want about the latter part of
fairy tale and the memes about nakama
power fake deaths and fanservice but the
magic was literally there in the first
few arcs that part of the show really
displayed mashima's pedigree in writing
light adventures and serious plots along
with creating characters that you all
grow to love and care about
2010
we've reached the end point of the video
so what does the anime world look like
well some show called chaon was raising
eyebrows left and right and ushering a
new age of kyoni dominance bringing in
loads and loads and loads of cash
through merchandise in the action side
of things well since we're in the topic
of fan service already why not give high
school ever dead a passing mention anime
trying to get into the impending zombie
media craze with this anime that with no
doubt immediately makes anyone think of
japan with one look at the character
designs neura rise of the yokai clan is
also such an underrated shonen it never
quite became as big as those in the tier
of say reborn which i think is just
criminal considering how intriguing the
series backdrop was and i was thoroughly
invested in the characters their
dynamics and their personal drama plus
it made yokai really cool and got me
interested in reading up on japanese
myths katana gathering and angel beats
are other landmark shows that got their
start this year angel beats already gets
a lot of love so i'd like to implore you
to try out katana ghatri and no it
doesn't have anything to do with araragi
hitaki and friends but hey it's written
by the same author as monogatari
so what's the action animate that takes
the last crowning spot
durarara it's ironic that i picked
durarara for 2010 when i gave the
victory to vagano a few years back
because the two series are strikingly
similar being written by the same author
durarara gives us a lot of the same that
we love about vocano only in a more
modern setting you get the great art the
interesting characters and a
surprisingly complex narrative that
opens up the idea of how much
perspectives matter when i won't say
that the characters are terribly complex
they have a charm that makes them stand
out and attractive in their own ways
it's not the perfect anime but it's got
a storytelling style that sets it apart
from its peers from the same year and a
unique approach that makes it stand out
to people looking to get into anime as a
whole so how did you find this decade in
review was there anything that i forgot
to mention that you think should have
been included well don't hesitate to
tell me i had a great time writing this
one and going through some of my most
cherished memories as a fan but if you
felt the same why don't you give a like
to the video and share it with your
friends too doing so will help the
algorithm and so we're going through my
channel and finding something that you
might like my patreon and channel
memberships are also open and really
love your help and support with that
that's going to do it for now and i'll
see you in the next list